bonjour et bienvenue dans ce premier
numéro 2012 de parlement hebdo
l'occasion pour nous bien sûr de vous
présenter nos voeux n'est ce pas
messieurs bonjour
alors cette année 2012 eh bien vous la
souhaite plus sereine que cette rentrée
parlementaire semaine marquée en effet
parler tire à boulet rouge entre
opposition et majorité à l'assemblée
projet de tva sociale contre le projet
de suppression du quotient familial
sa dernière proposition qui a pris la
lourde un nouveau couac de l'équipe
hollande
on y reviendra les petites phrases
assassines ont aussi émaillé les voeux
françois fillon qui tacle françois
hollande de diabolisation infantile
bernard accoyer qui parle de guerre aux
cas de rendez vous raté avec 2012
mauvais climat à tel point que nicolas
sarkozy et martine aubry en ont parlé
ensemble devant les caméras image qui
est bien sûr a fait le buzz enfin nous
reviendrons sur l' affaire qui met en
cause lit gs la police des police elle
aurait truqué une enquête pour mettre en
cause les policiers proches des
socialistes à l'assemblée comme au sénat
clos glee ont été sommés par les
socialistes de sexe car tu peut
s'expliquer mauvais climat décidément à
100 jours de l'élection présidentielle
est notre invité cette semaine et didier
guillaume bonjour j'ai peur socialiste
de la drôme vous êtes aussi le président
du conseil général et depuis est bien
septembre depuis que le sénat a basculé
à gauche vous êtes devenu de vice
président du sénat vous êtes d'ailleurs
très proche du nouveau président jean
pierre bel
on a même vu beaucoup à la manoeuvre
pendant et après cette élection que ce
soit avec les verts avec le parti
socialiste
ou bien même avec la droite et certains
sénateurs socialistes disent même que
vous êtes l'homme qui démine le terrain
voir le bras droit de son kernel alors
votre réponse sur ces quelques
interrogations
c'est plutôt un compliment prenez ça
comme un compliment d'être en passe
d'être en phase avec le président du
du sénat c'est vrai que nous sommes
proches depuis des années et puis
surtout d'essayer de faire en sorte que
au sénat nous vivions une démocratie
politique apaisée cela ne veut pas dire
qu'il n'y a pas de conflit qu'il n'y a
pas de débats parfois un peu difficile
mais ce qu'il veut ce qu'il faut et ce
que veut le président du sénat c'est que
cette institution garde son histoire
certains disent aussi et notamment à
droite évidemment au sénat que ce sénat
a changé qu'il est devenu plus partisan
peut-être est-ce aussi le fait qu'on va
bientôt basculer vers la campagne
électorale à moins de 100 jours
maintenant de cette campagne
mais le sénat ce n'est pas un club de 3e
âge où on fait là on joue aux cartes
l'après midi le sénat est une chambre
politique
donc c'est normal que la politique soit
dans le sénat je ne suis pas sûr
d'ailleurs que avant le 1er octobre la
politique n'était pas présente non plus
faut voir par exemple comment les
sénateurs ont voté au canon la réforme
des collectivités territoriales
simplement à 100 jours de l'élection
présidentielle
peut-être que la nature change un peu et
les femmes et les hommes du sénat parce
que les femmes et les hommes au sénat
les sénatrices et sénateurs attendent
avec impatience de rentrer dans la dans
cette bataille la bataille reine de la
démocratie politique française en tout
cas on peut être être dépoussiéré
l'image du sénat vous parlais tout à
l'heure le club de 3e âge c'est parfois
l'image que certains avaient trait au
regard des séances aujourd'hui on change
d'avis c'est plutôt dire une chose le
bicamérisme rénové en france tient à
coeur au président et nous tient à coeur
et je pense qu'il faut vraiment il faut
vraiment que le sénat joue son rôle
peuple alors didier guillaume on va
dérouler le fil de la semaine avec vous
et on va commencer lundi avec les voeux
de françois fillon un premier ministre à
l'offensive
pour le premier ministre ce sont les
derniers voeux du quinquennat la
tonalité était tout électorale françois
fillon a sonné la charge contre françois
hollande accusé de se livrer à une
diabolisation infantile de la situation
de la france bref le premier ministre
s'est lancé lui aussi dans le combat de
2012 fabrice culine eh bien allons à
l'assaut de cette année 2012 est la
cible des attaques s'appelle françois
hollande
rarement des voeux à la presse auront
été aussi offensif face aux critiques du
candidat socialiste françois fillon n'a
pas ménagé ses mots
à écouter monsieur hollande tous nés
qu'échec iniquité désolation bref notre
pays et dans le gouffre je combats cette
maladie
la charge du soldat fillon vise
particulièrement le programme du
candidat socialiste ou plutôt l'absence
d'un programme clair
attendons qu'il explique précisément
comment il entend réduire les déficits
parce que pour l'instant c'est le flou
absolu
on nous parle du paquet fiscal de la
suppression de la réforme de liesse f
des niches fiscales
inutile de vous dire que le compte n'y
est pas et de loin
pour le premier ministre le bilan de
nicolas sarkozy et de son gouvernement
est plus que respectable dans un
contexte jugé compliqué françois fillon
a défendu ses résultats il a aussi
défendu l'image de ce quinquennat
je n'accepte pas ce projet ce procès
injurieux sur le prétendu gouvernement
des riches
que dirait d'ailleurs les socialistes
nous les les cieux si nous laissions
entendre qu'ils sont à la solde ou sous
la coupe d'une partie de nos concitoyens
ça c'est le degré zéro de la politique
et pour le premier ministre françois
hollande se livre tout simplement à une
diabolisation infantile le président
sortant n'est pas encore officiellement
en campagne mais françois fillon et déjà
son premier porte parole alors didier
guillaume qu'est ce que vous pensez des
attaques de françois fillon l'a retenu
parle de scorpio need autolyse bref
c'est l'instinct destructeur qui
pousserait à s'empoisonner lui-même
comme le fait le scorpion est ce que ça
va pas un petit peu loin
je crois que les français n'ont pas
compris tout
toutes ces attaques d'abord sur leur
consonance bien sûr jouer sur les mots
nouveaux que personne ne connaissait il
faut ranger les snipers au placard ce
n'est pas le temps de la présidentielle
ce n'est pas ce n'est pas le temps ce ne
doit pas être le temps de tous les
dérapages
le premier ministre a mieux à faire que
cela ils attaquent quand même un
parlementaire de la république est un
candidat à l'élection présidentielle
et si on rajoute lé danger la guerre et
tout cela ce n'est pas de vendre des
choses justes sur les snipers laurent
fabius avait dit au sein même du parti
socialiste
il faut des snipers c'est lui qui avait
employé ce terme donc vous êtes en
contradiction avec une loi du tout mais
je pense que lorsqu'il ya des snipers
d'un côté il faut répondre
nous n'avons pas attendre et l'équipe de
françois hollande ne va pas attendre que
les choses se passent et en prendre
plein la figure excusez moi cette
expression triviale mais à mon sens nos
concitoyens aujourd'hui dans la crise
certains dans la misère avec 30% d'entre
eux qui sont prêts peut-être à voter ou
à partager des thèses du front national
je parle là tant mieux que c'est
justement l'argument que reprend x 100
transactions quand il parle de
diabolisme infantile est ce que
l'antisarkozysme est la bonne réponse
justement dans ce climat de crise grave
que nous connaissons mais
l'antisarkozysme est une des réponses
cette campagne présidentielle se fera
sur deux niveaux le bilan du président
sarkozy et les propositions de françois
hollande
le bilan du candidat sarkozy est
nullissime ce médiocre
ça a été un quinquennat de division et
non pas un candidat d'un quinquennat de
rassemblement il faudra le dire et 7 6
epr est perçue compte de l'article anti
sarkozysme ce n'est pas la personne du
chef de l'état mais c'est sa politique
alors que de l'autre côté des attaques
sont vous avez de la personne de
françois hollande
et puis il faudra aussi dans cette
campagne électorale faire des
propositions avoir de la cohérence nous
y reviendront sûrement
et c'est dans ce cadre là qu'il faut
faire attention moi je fais partie de
ceux qui pensent que la démocratie
française
l'élection possible française vaut mieux
que des petites phrases que des tweeters
incessants que des tweets incessants et
tout cela sur facebook twitter où on
voit un petit peu toutes ses phrases
et ces hommes politiques qui twitte
c'est pas bien c'est la négation de la
politique twitter c'est la négation de
la plaisance r aujourd'hui je dirais pas
que l'on s'en sert pas c'est la négation
de la politique la politique c'est
argumenté
c'est débattre jeudi 3 40 signe ça ne
s'est pas en s'enquérant tine et ce
n'est pas non ce n'est pas d'envoyer une
phrase avec un seul objectif espéré
d'être repris derrière par une dépêche
afp et par les médias et peut-être par
vous-même d'ailleurs c'est un jeu à mon
avis tu pas terrible oui c'est
uniquement de la communication on va
passer au mardi un jour qui n'est pas
meilleur que le lundi pour françois
hollande
le cauchemar de jours pour françois
hollande tient en deux mots quotient
familial
en ce mardi matin manuel valls
responsable de la communication annonce
sa suppression et son remplacement par
un crédit d'impôt plus égalitaire dans
l'après-midi françois hollande modère le
propos mais trop tard à l'assemblée la
majorité s'est engouffré dans la brèche
jean baptiste daoulas tout commence avec
une déclaration de manuel valls eu ce
matin le responsable de la communication
de françois hollande confirme une
information des échos
le projet socialiste proposera de
remplacer le quotient familial par un
crédit d'impôt une rupture avec des
décennies de politique fiscale familial
que nicolas sarkozy exploite aussitôt
abroger le quotient familial aurait des
conséquences absolument dramatiques pour
la politique familiale de la nation à
l'assemblée l'ump se chargent de
pilonner le projet du camp hollande avec
un message remettre en cause le quotient
familial c'est pénaliser les classes
moyennes des familles qui aujourd'hui ne
paient pas d'impôts parce qu'ils ont des
enfants à charge
demain en paieraient 4 millions et demi
de ménages seraient concernés pour une
augmentation d'impôts moyenne
deux mille euros en fin de journée le
camp hollande 2 corrige le tir
le candidat explique qu à quelques
journalistes qu'il n'est pas question de
supprimer le quotient familial mais tout
simplement de le module et une précision
que ces lieux dont martell pour éteindre
l'incendié
il y aura une modulation de l'aide
fiscale apporter aux familles
quelquefois les mots peuvent changer on
peut avoir l'impression qu'un dispositif
est supprimé moi ce que je dis c'est que
nous garderons une politique familiale
forte mais elle devra être plus juste
qu'elle ne l'est aujourd'hui c'est en ce
sens que le quotient familial va évoluer
va être modulée va être transformée avec
le débat sur le quotient familial les
classes moyennes s'impose comme l'un des
grands enjeux de la campagne un
électorat aussi décisif que difficile à
cerner pour les candidats nés guillaume
bonnaud le rouzic les mots peuvent
changer
sur un sujet aussi sensible un coup on
parle de suppression du quotient
familial
un peu plus tard de modulation est ce
qu'il faut pas être extrêmement précis
et est ce que ce flottement n'est pas
préjudiciable
il faut sûrement être précis
permettez-moi en une minute de répondre
en trois parties et cette question
première partie une réponse politicienne
c'est quand même beaucoup moins grave
que l'équipe de holland au moment où
elles réfléchissent son programme et des
ajustements à faire que lorsque le
gouvernement quitte à la manoeuvre est
autant de divergences par exemple entre
le ministre des transports et le présent
de la république sur la sphère de
seafrance ou au niveau de la tva sociale
au niveau institutionnel
il est inacceptable que le président de
la république avec les impôts des
français face des voeux dans toute la
france il a le droit mais dans son
discours n'avoir qu'un seul objectif
c'est de parler du candidat socialiste
du candidat françois hollande
et puis la réponse sur une science
familiale sur le quotient familial et
l'arrêt et sur d'autres sujets et la
réponse sur le fond qui est là qui quand
même la plus forte et la plus importante
pour moi c'est que si aujourd'hui la
gauche et françois hollande vont à
l'élection présidentielle avec les mêmes
recettes éculées que celles qui ont été
mises en place dans le passé nous irons
dans le mur
un discours clair unis cielo errant sur
des sujets majeurs laurent il faut une
photo un discours clair françois
hollande holden et sec
ne l'est pas trop ce jour non qu'il ya
eu il ya eu plusieurs couacs disons le
est alors est gravissime
au moment où les socialistes sont en
train d'affiner leur projet françois
hollande a dit clairement
seule ma parole compte il présentera son
programme et sa cohérence dans quelques
semaines pour l'instant c'est ce qu'on
disait tout à l'heure avec les moyens
modernes de communication
chaque mot prononcé est un mot qui
repris directement j'aurais préféré que
cela ne se passe pas comme ça comme ça
s'est passé
on est d'accord et alors c'est quand
même pas gravissime on est en train de
caler le programme est aujourd'hui dire
que le quotient familial est injuste et
qu'il faut le faire évoluer
c'est aller dans le sens de la modernité
sur le fond vous allez quand même vous
en prendre aux classes moyennes
notamment supérieur mais ces classes
moyennes ces classes populaires est ce
que vous avez vraiment l'impression de
vous adresser à l ena pas l'impression
plutôt de partir vers le front national
en ce moment non je ne crois pas du tout
au contraire les sondages et les
chiffres montrent que ces classes
populaires se dirige à presque 22 %
aujourd'hui sont prêts à voter pour le
front national parce que la politique
menée par le président de la république
et par le gouvernement en place depuis
cinq ans et la politique depuis dix ans
a conduit à cela c'est quand même palais
à cause des socialistes que les gens se
retournent vers le front national
nous voulons changer une l'absence de
mesures de propositions mais les
propositions vont arriver vont arriver
le 22 janvier c'est françois hollande a
ouvert son local il ya de cela quelques
jours le premier acte qu'il a fait c'est
de recevoir les partenaires sociaux
changement de logiciel intellectuelle
ensuite il y aura la gueule de grands
rassemblements de du 22 janvier au
bourget là où il commencera à élaborer
la stratégie et la présentation du
programme ensuite ans le 22 et ensuite
il l'a dit très clairement sur la sphère
du quotient familial revenant en
revanche bien un petit peu si vous le
permettez sûr de quoi s'agit-il
plus j'ai de l'argent plus j'ai de
l'enfant plus j'ai des enfants plus
l'état me
donne de la donne des sous moi j'ai
d'argent mois il m'en donne c'est quand
même très injuste n'allons pas à
l'élection présidentielle de 2012 avec
les mêmes recettes éculées que par le
passé il faut mais de la justice sociale
françois deux choses
pas un euro ne sera enlevée à la
politique familiale française
pas un euro ne sera enlevé la politique
familiale française et en même temps à
l'intérieur de cette masse ceux qui ont
beaucoup d'argent devront en toucher un
peu moins par rapport à ceux qui en ont
pas c'est clair et ça sera entendu par
les gens les plus en difficulté et par
les classes moyennes
l'éducation est pas une suppression
parce qu'il y avait eu un calcul qui a
été fait ces aveux suppression avait
crédit d'impôt de 6 ans 7 euros par
enfant ça c'était défavorable à tous
ceux soyez fiscaux qui touchait plus de
4200 euros brut par mois ce qui ne
représente pas à deux à deux ans de
salaire
on est d'accord c'est un chalet
réactionnaire et puis surtout pourquoi
il ne faut pas supprimer le quotient
familial pour l'immense majorité des
françaises et des français qui mettent
leurs enfants à la cantine sur la base
du quotient familial qui mettent leurs
enfants le mercredi aux opérations
sportives sur la base du quotient
familial à la médiathèque
la suppression du quotient familial
n'aurait pas été une bonne chose mais sa
modulation est indispensable pour plus
de justice
rdio vous l'avez dit mercredi françois
hollande a inauguré son siège de
campagne
le candidat socialiste a inauguré son qg
avenue de ségur à paris le but de cette
opération très médiatique donner une
image d'unité après la cacophonie de ces
derniers jours au portage crime du phare
opération portes ouvertes au siège de
campagne de françois hollande
un hôtel particulier mille mètres carrés
dans le très chic 7e arrondissement de
paris loyer 40000 euros par mois en
cause toujours des anciens premier
ministres aux anciens rivaux à la
primaire tous les ténors ont fait le
déplacement
une image d'unité pour faire oublier les
couacs sur le quotient familial
la france et la république c'est
l'égalité et je pense que beaucoup
d'hommes et de femmes qu'il soit à
droite ou qu'ils soient bien sûr à
gauche pensent comme moi que l'égalité
apportée par la république à chacun par
la fiscalité est très importante voilà
alors qu'on ne nous caricature pas oui
il faut une politique familiale en
france il faut qu'elle soit juste
françois hollande refuse de répondre aux
critiques de la droite il est prêt pour
la bataille des 100 jours avant la
présidentielle
le combat sera rude je le sais dans les
comparaisons animalières
j'ai maintenant droit à toutes les
catégories
certains pensent même que je suis un
danger pour la france belle conception
de la démocratie
il a dévoilé son slogan le changement
c'est maintenant une référence au
célèbre changer la vie de françois
mitterrand ce slogan ou de trouver des
arrangements sur la tente
le
je lève la tête pour le pour le
découvrir oui enfin c'est dansant le
candidat présentera son programme fin
janvier un texte inspiré du projet
socialiste et qui tiendra compte du
contexte économique
alors des digues et yom vous y étiez
vous étiez présent lors de cette
inauguration
cette image d'unité ça change de 2007
finalement est ce que on à solder les
comptes du passé au parti socialiste
je pense que les sociétés sont tirées
les leçons les enseignements du mas et
le début de campagne l'entrée en
campagne de ségolène royal en 2007
n'avait pas été bonne le parti
socialiste le parti socialiste n'était
pas rassemblé derrière ségolène royal et
moi je les ai beaucoup reproché ce n'est
pas le cas aujourd'hui
les primaires citoyennes quand est
organisée en donner de la force à
françois hollande est aujourd'hui tout
le monde est derrière
même martine aubry même martine aubry
vous l'avez vu encore à ses voeux en
début de semaine bien sûr l'enjeu
aujourd'hui est de faire en sorte qu'il
y ait un changement que le changement
soit maintenant en france et qu'il y une
note politique à celle soulevée
j'en ai profité pour vous le rappeler
mais j'ai connu un début de campagne
réussie françois hollande la campagne
n'a pas démarré encore la campagne
démarre la campagne a démarré à
l'ouverture du local il ya de cela
quelques jours on est en train de faire
le programme le début de campagne et
très bon vous savez beaucoup de
candidats socialistes dans les années
passent et aurait aimé se retrouver à
100 jours du premier tour avec 27 ou 28
% d'intentions de vote au premier tour
et avec 57% d'intentions de vote oral
avec les verts on considère pas que
c'est un début de campagne s'était
avancé le passé les quads du passé tout
ça mais moi finir j'ai regardé très
franchement mais vraiment très
franchement parce qu'il faut pas faire
grand de bois aujourd'hui plus personne
ne l'acceptent
il ya des choses qui ont été faits qui
n'ont pas été bien fait et françois
hollande en train de rectifier le tir
sur plein de sujets notamment l'accord
entre le parti socialiste et europe
écologie les verts ne correspond pas à
la volonté totale sur le nucléaire par
exemple de ce que réfé françois hollande
ça va se rectifier il faut bien
considérer qu'il y a deux choses il ya
d'accord entre les partis politiques
pour les législatives
ils sont essentiels une majorité de
gauche
accompagner la politique du président
hollande et puis il ya la campagne du
candidat françois hollande et ses
propres orientations savez il ya des
vagues attendait beaucoup de la
présentation du programme pour améliorer
l'image du candidat
moi j'attends beaucoup parce que je vais
vous faire une confidence françois
hollande va vous surprendre va nous
surprendre
il va surprendre les français beaucoup
de français disent on l'entend il est
mou il n'a pas tranché puis on nous
rabat les oreilles tous les jours dans
les médias et vous verrez que françois
hollande a déjà donné des exemples mais
il sait trancher
il aura la capacité de rassembler tout
le monde de cliver lorsqu'il y aura
besoin
il a dit clairement je ne me laisserai
pas faire je ne laisserai pas marcher
sur les pieds ni par les uns ni par les
autres il va nous surprendre dans sa
façon d'aborder cette campagne
présidentielle comme jamais cela a été
le cas encore qui va nous dire j'ai
changé je suis devenu plus leur nom et
l'art comme on va pas recommencer
reprendre les amis d'autres je n'ai pas
changé
la question est tout simplement de dire
je suis maintenant investi par les
citoyens de gauche qui ont voté pour moi
pour une chose je veux être une chance
pour la france en étant président de la
république c'était ça le changement
c'est maintenant le changement c'est
maintenant
alors mercredi toujours c'était les
voeux du président de l'assemblée
bernard accoyer
là encore à 100 jours de l'élection
présidentielle la tonalité est à
l'offensive
bernard acoyer parle de conséquences
comparables à celles d'une guerre si le
rendez-vous 2012 est manquée la réaction
des socialistes est immédiate jean
baptiste daoulas tout est parti d'une
phrase prononcée par bernard accoyer
dans son discours de voeux le président
de l'assemblée nationale s'inquiète pour
le quotient familial
la politique familiale et l'industrie
nucléaire française
après les élections de 2012 et il
enchaîne ne nous y trompons pas si nous
ratons ce rendez-vous de la
responsabilité du courage
les conséquences économiques et sociales
pourrait être comparable à celle
provoquée par une guerre bernard accoyer
ne parle pas directement d'une victoire
de la gauche mais les socialistes eux se
sentent visés par la métaphore guerrière
hors de question de laisser passer la
petite phrase qu'est ce que c'est que
cette conception de la démocratie
moi je demande que monsieur accoyer s'il
veut être digne de la fonction qu'il
occupe retire ses propos et présente ses
excuses mais pas seulement à nous
françois hollande qui les présentent aux
français parce que la démocratie c'est
qu'elle a un bien précieux
la démocratie ça se respecte votez
débattent ça fait partie bien entendu de
la base de la démocratie
la petite phrase de bernard accoyer a
même donné lieu à un communiqué plutôt
étonné de la part du président
socialiste du sénat jean-pierre bel
face à la polémique bernard accoyer
maintient pourtant ces propos je pense
que mes propos ont été tronqués ou
déformés donc il n'y a pas d'ambiguïté
je ne stigmatise personne jeudi que la
situation est telle qu'en l'absence de
prise en compte de cette situation par
quelques majorité ou quelques présidents
que ce soient les conséquences pour la
france et les français seraient
considérables la campagne 2012 est bel
et bien lancée plus que jamais chaque
déclaration devrait être pesé au mot
près didier guillon vous a été convaincu
par la dana explications de bernard
acoyer qu'il a répété cette semaine ils
l'on voulait pas du tout aux socialistes
disais juste que c'est le contexte
économique si on ne faisait pas face qui
a mené à des conséquences de guerre il
ya 30 ans nous a fait le coup des chars
soviétiques sur les champs-elysées la
place de la concorde si françois
mitterrand était élu ressortir 10 des
recettes éculées
si c'était pas honteux de l'avoir fait
comme cela ça pourrait nous faire rire
mais franchement moi mon père a été
résistant il a fait la guerre il s'est
battu pour la france
et nous dans la région rhône alpes et
dans le dans la drôme on connaît ce
qu'elle vercors ce que sont les maquis
prendre cet exemple là c'est pas digne
d'un président de l'assemblée nationale
adresse
mais c'est pas une maladresse lorsqu on
n'y revient pas derrière les lorsque don
ne s'excuse pas d'ailleurs j'ai entendu
avec beaucoup d'intérêt les propos du
président de la république il y a deux
ou trois jours à lille lorsqu'il est
intervenu
moi je pense que le président acoyer
s'il veut garder de la crédibilité pour
les quelques semaines qui restent à la
présidence de l'assemblée nationale
devait vraiment s'excuser ou retirer
cette phrase tous les mots sont
importants en politique comme ailleurs
mais en ce moment tout particulièrement
ce qu'on voit que on s'engouffre très
facilement dans la
moindre maladresse si on estime c'est ce
que nous disions tout à l'heure il faut
faire très attention notamment du
quatrième personnage de l'état
alors vous parliez justement de réaction
nicolas sarkozy alors ce climat
politique très tendu à susciter un
échange verbal plutôt étonnant nicolas
sarkozy était à lille pour ses voeux aux
fonctionnaires il a évidemment croiser
la maire de lille martine aubry et voilà
ce que ça a donné on écoute
merci
si la femme
regardez au gia
sont pas très bons mais on sait tous ce
titre est donc ils partagent cet avis
sur bernard acoyer le duo c'est très
jeune et changer de nom il désavoue
totalement ça été amusant cet échange
d'ailleurs entre les leaders de
l'opposition et le chef de la majorité
mais je pense que c'est bien aussi dans
un climat comme cela à 100 jours de la
présidentielle
eh bien les responsables politiques
puissent puissent se parler c'est un
échange républicains le président de la
république va à lille martine aubry lui
a dit très courageusement ce qu'il en
était elle n'aura pas un deuxième vélo
cette année parce qu'elle n'a pas et
n'est pas d'humeur à lui offrir un
nouveau cadeau juste qu'il a fait aux
français
et puis là dessus dire calmer votre ou
quoi ça va quand même un peu loin et
justement certains à gauche au parti
socialiste dise vous voyez si ç'avait
été martine aubry face à nicolas sarkozy
ou à la ce que ça aurait pu être pire je
ne comprends pas la question que
peut-être que martine aubry aurait pu
être une candidate plus musclée
peut-être que françois hollande
les bois vous dites ça c'est les gens du
parti socialiste qui en parlent pas les
gens du parti socialiste qu'elle jean
dupont des sites et des sénateurs mais
ce que je sais ce que je constate
aujourd'hui c'était que le président de
la réplique d'état lille
tant mieux si martine aubry réagit comme
cela moi j'ai confiance en elle sauf que
le la démocratie le peuple a tranché et
que c'est françois hollande le candidat
et je vous disais tout à l'heure vous
verrez lorsqu'il aura à débattre face à
nicolas sarkozy ce qu'il en est je pense
que plus personne nous dira cela parce
qu'ils se diront finalement évidemment
nous avons le meilleur candidat et sur
ce climat de campagne
roselyne bachelot une ministre qui dit
on n'est pas dans le monde des
bisounours mais évidemment on est dans
un monde difficile et serré est ce que
nous vivons en france par rapport à ce
qui se passe aux etats-unis et qu'elle
voir tous les jours entre madame clinton
et monsieur obama lors de la primaire
c'était chaud et entre les candidats
c'est chaud tôt que ça veut dire que à
gauche comme à droite remet axel que ce
soit un climat on va dire un petit peu
engagés il faut de la différenciation le
clivage c'est simple il faut du clivage
il faut qu entre la droite et la gauche
on voit qu'il ya une différence mais
cela ne doit pas laisser la porte
ouverte à ce que vous avez vous appelé
dans le jargon des snipers à toutes
celles et tous ceux qui vont flinguer
tous les jours je pense que la
démocratie n'a pas besoin de ça et
regarder quand même qui attaque et qui
est les plus durs et regarder que
parallèlement pourquoi le front national
n'en fait elle se poser des questions
aussi
alors mercredi la tournée des voeux de
nicolas sarkozy se poursuit il recevait
à l'elysée les parlementaires l'occasion
pour le président de donner quelques
bons points aux députés comment
sénateurs écouter le changement de
majorité au sénat sur le président en
septembre dernier n'est que la dernière
illustration de la longue série des
exemples qui démontrent que nos
institutions relève d'un subtil
équilibre qu'il serait absolument
insensé de vouloir bouleverser
je ne doute pas d'ailleurs que ceux qui
plaidaient il y à peu encore pour la
disparition du sénat verrons dans
l'alternance au sénat une raison de
préserver une institution bien utile à
l' équilibre dans notre république
alors didier guillaume c'est plutôt un
satisfecit même pour le sénat passer à
gauche mais c'est bien c'est parce que
lorsque les choses on les entend comme
cela il faut se dire c'est bien le
président de la république se
rencontrent se rend compte qu'il était
utile d'avoir une alternance au sénat
que senna a bien travaillé
contrairement à ce que l'on entend tous
les jours par certains membres de la
majorité bien ça fait deux fois dans la
semaine qui vous apaise le jeune entre
bernard acoyer ce groupe je pense que
c'est très tactique
cela dit ce qui est dit un rôle du
président c'est le rôle du président ce
que le président se disent accoyer a
dérapé et disent finalement au sénat on
y travaille on y travaille bien mais
c'est plutôt bien pour nous ça renforce
notre argumentation
il le pense vraiment je voulais
ressembler de la tactique
donc on vit dans un monde aussi
d'apparence l'événement dit il a
également dit et ça ça vous intéresse
peut-être premier chef que les élus
locaux serait bientôt reçu pour leur
demander de faire des efforts au temps
de crise vous qui est aussi président du
conseil général de la drôme
est ce que vous allez aller à cette
rencontre avec nicolas sarkozy est ce
que vous serez prêt à faire des efforts
mais ce sont aux élus locaux de recevoir
sarkozy pour qu'il s'explique sur ce
qu'il a fait ce qu'il a détricoté
pendant son mandat
qu'est ce que c'est cette histoire où le
président de la république va recevoir
les élus locaux
c'est son droit et
associations iront vraisemblablement
mais enfin si ce fichier de la figure du
monde
aujourd'hui il n'y a pas une
collectivité locale qui ne fait pas
d'effort qu'ils ne gèrent pas au plus
serré la dette des collectivités locales
il n'y en a quasiment pas la dette de
l'état augmentent tous les jours donc je
pense vraiment de l'art et d'efforts
supplémentaires c'est une opération de
communication les locaux font des
efforts tous les jours et s'ils doivent
en faire encore ils en feront parce que
ce sont de bons gestionnaires
globalement à 99% mais c'est quand même
là aussi une opération tactique j'ai
perdu le sénat
les locaux condamne la politique donc je
vais les recevoir pour leur expliquer
que nous sommes en phase c'est quand
même les drôles d drôle de façon de
procéder par le premier groupe
écologique écologistes de l'histoire du
parlement français s'est constitué
formellement ce mercredi il s'appelle le
groupe écologiste sont dix ils veulent
transformer le sénat en chambre des
régions et c'est le numéro deux d'europe
écologie les verts jean vincent placé
qui va en prendre la présidence
vous avez beaucoup négocié avec les
verts à l'occasion et bien du passage à
gauche du sénat
on se rappelle vouloir souhaiter bon
courage a dit ça va être compliqué de
gérer
ce qu'il y à faire au sénat que ce soit
d'être présent commission dans
l'hémicycle jeu compliqué je leur ai dit
lorsque nous avons discuté dans la
semaine des sénatoriales mais c'est un
choix politique et un accord politique
un groupe au sénat un groupe à
l'assemblée la gauche est pluriel pour
reprendre un mot anciens et donc c'est
normal que les écologistes et leur
groupe au sénat
ils sont 10 ce sera sans aucun doute
difficile quand on voit leur audience en
ce moment au niveau national qui est
quand même extrêmement bas dans les
intentions de sondage
est ce qu'il est normal qu'ils aient
comme ça un groupe dans les deux
assemblées
aujourd'hui parce que c'est une
formation politique qui est qui
représentait au niveau national peut
être qu'aujourd'hui dans les intentions
de vote
madame joly fait un très faible score
mais reconnaissons qu'un cause
européenne qu'aux régionales que dans
les autres élections aux élections
cantonales ou municipales les
écologistes sont présents donc c'est
bien qu'ils soient représentés au
parlement
maintenant pour répondre à votre
question ce sera sûrement dure pour eux
de tout assumer ils ont sur l'autonomie
notamment sur les votes pour juste un
exemple il ya bientôt ce texte sur le
sanctionnant la négation du génocide est
par exemple du génocide arménien on a
beaucoup parlé ces dernières semaines et
votre rencontre
le parti socialiste a priori votre amour
vous voyez là un problème par rapport
aux verts non mais là nous sommes avec
des groupes politiques au parlement et
chaque groupe politique à partir du
moment où il existe est autonome
par contre nous mettons en place une
coordination des groupes de la majorité
où les présidents de groupes vont se
voir régulièrement afin d'affiner de nos
positions et de regarder les choses et
puis sur les sujets qui comprennent
vraiment les fondements mêmes les
questions de morale les questions de
individuelle et bien évidemment les
groupes auront leur liberté de vote
parce que c'est la démocratie
allez on ce mercredi toujours c'est le
quotidien le monde qui révèle une
affaire qui met en cause lit gs la
police des polices accusée d'avoir
truqué une enquête pour compromettre
quatre policiers proches des socialistes
dans le collimateur des juges
michel gaudin a tué le préfet de police
de paris et proche de nicolas sarkozy
explication de la m hier à l'assemblée
nationale
daniel vaillant sort de sa discrétion
pour lui il n'y a aucun doute
l'enquète de la police des polices sur
trois fonctionnaires proches de lui est
une manipulation dont il est lui aussi
victime je crois savoir qu'il ya eu des
procès verbaux falsifiés par exemple
quand même pas une petite affaire
surtout qu' il ya eu d'autres petites
affaires concernant le gsc dérives
notamment dans la fameuse affaire des
fadettes
donc il ya récidive réitération
ce qui veut dire qu'il ya un vrai
problème et je pense qu'il faut prendre
que le ministre de l'intérieur en dehors
de la réparation qu'il doit aux victimes
il faut qu'il prenne des dispositions
immédiates par rapport à cette
institution qui m'apparaît comme peu
fiables retour sur les faits nous sommes
au lendemain de l'élection
présidentielle de 2007
trois fonctionnaires de police proche du
parti socialiste sont accusés de
corruption furent des titres de séjour
lee j ai semaine l'enquète et aurait
selon le journal le monde
trafic et des procès verbaux pour
accabler les fonctionnaires de police
proche du ps
l'enquète mènera un non lieu les
fonctionnaires de gauche seront blanchis
les regards sont désormais braqués sur
les policiers de droite cible cette fois
michel gaudin le préfet de police de
paris
un proche de nicolas sarkozy qui serait
au coeur des accusations de truquage du
dossier à l'assemblée le ministre de
l'intérieur défend son subordonné le
préfet de police
israël son douar réponses auprès du
journal qui a publié ses indications
ils se réservent de donner les suites
judiciaires appropriées mais je voudrais
rappeler un principe de notre république
c'est que quand la justice est saisie
on la laisse travailler dans les
couloirs des cas de colonne à droite
autant de calmer le jeu
moi je vois dans ce dossier aucun lien
avec la politique
les sons en toute indépendance la
justice travailler et voici la police
des polices ans et démasquer les ripoux
accusé d'être ripoux elle-même
après l'histoire des fadettes un
scandale de plus qui risquent
d'embarrasser nicolas sarkozy à trois
mois de la présidentielle
alors bruno le roux porte parole de
campagne de françois hollande a mis
directement en cause claude guéant
disant qu'il était à l'époque au coeur
de la faire à l'époque il était
directeur de cabinet de nicolas sarkozy
ni l'intérieur claude guéant menace de
porter plainte pour diffamation
est-ce qu'il faut voir la main du
politique dans cette affaire il n'y a
pas de fumée sans feu aurait dit ma
grand mère donc il ya une enquête en
cours
il faut la laisser se dérouler mais
enfin cela commence à faire beaucoup
où est la république irréprochable
lorsqu'on voit la sphère du monde et des
fadettes lorsque l'on voit cela
il ya quand même un faisceau de
présomptions qui font que
vraisemblablement la main du politique
est derrière tout cela mais
vraisemblement on n'en sait rien donc là
enquête est en cours
ça risque de durer un peu je pense tout
ça ça crée aussi un mauvais climat et
quand alors vous me posez des questions
du front national
ça aussi c'est parti les français ne
veulent pas de tous ces passe droits le
président du groupe socialiste au sénat
parle d'une utilisation de la police à
des fins partisanes c'est peut-être un
peu dur non est ce pas un peu réel n'est
ce pas un peu réel c'est ça c'est ça
qu'il faut regarder
alors c'est sûrement dure mais la
situation aujourd'hui dire lorsque l'on
voit ce qui se passe aujourd'hui dans la
peau ni son plus haut niveau de l'état
on peut se poser des questions moi je
n'ai pas de réponse je ne suis pas un
spécialiste
donc nous allons nous allons attendre
enfin il ya un faisceau quand même de
settat faisceau n'y a pas vraiment de
réponse
une utilisation de cette affaire aussi à
des fins partisanes là aussi mais c'est
sur la place publique le journal le
monde l'a révélé il ya eu des articles
dans libération donc à partir de là
c'est sur la place publique ça fait
partie du domaine public et à partir de
là nous avons besoin nous de nous poser
certaines questions et les chances de
voir sortir maintenant a justement 100
jours de la présidentielle pas vous dire
c'est le sait la responsabilité des
journalistes
mais c'est quand même un peu étonnant
surtout de s'apercevoir que j'ai des
cazilhacois se poser des questions sur
ce qui peut se passer
voilà c'est gravissime tous là à passer
au jeudi le sénat se penche sur les
comptes de campagne
votée à l'assemblée amendée par la
gauche au sénat le projet de loi prévoit
le contrôle des budgets de campagne pour
les prétendants à l'elysée jeudi
la gauche a profité de ce débat pour
dénoncer l'utilisation des moyens de
l'état par nicolas sarkozy candidat
encore non déclarés des explications de
son brassard car la commission des
comptes de campagne la firme et les
déplacements de nicolas sarkozy pourront
être intégrées à son futur budget de
candidats un avis qui n'a rien de
contraignant alors au sénat la gauche je
veux passer par la loi
un des amendements votés aujourd'hui
précise que toutes les dépenses engagées
12 mois avant un scrutin ont bien
caractère électoral la fréquence des
déplacements du président de la
république s'est accélérée depuis
plusieurs mois notre collègue rené
dosière à l'assemblée nationale a tenu
un comptage précis il nous indique que
durant les trois premières années de la
présidence la moyenne était d'une
cinquantaine de déplacements par an et
subitement dans l'année qui précède les
élections ces dépassements sont passées
à plus de 70 avec évidemment un net
accroissement en cette période de
nouvelles années le gouvernement n'avait
pas l'intention au travers de ce texte
de redéfinir les règles de
fonctionnement de la 5eme république
derechef irles et les prérogatives du
chef de l'état la majorité de gauche au
sénat profite du projet de loi du
gouvernement sur les comptes de campagne
pour critiquer nicolas sarkozy président
pas encore déclaré mais qui ferait
campagne aux frais de l'état
selon le député ps rené dosière une
visite du président en france coûterait
près de 93 mille euros mais en 2012 les
candidats à la présidentielle devront se
serrer la ceinture
en plus d'une diminution de 5% du
remboursement des frais de campagne
un gel des plafonds de dépenses a été
mis en place
rigueur oblige ces deux amendements
délégués ou quand tu étais a voté au
sénat est donc pas des amendements
spécial spéciaux contre nicolas sarkozy
ils sont pas ceux pêchés au conflit
colas sarkozy mais enfin ils tiennent
compte de la réalité des la réalité des
choses d'abord je dois dire
ici qu'en période de crise tout le monde
doit faire des efforts et qu'il est bien
que l'état rembourse pas autant que les
autres années les comptes de campagne
des candidats
c'est une bonne chose et nous sommes
tous d'accord sur leurs gouvernements
puisque nous étions d'accord avec ce
projet de loi pourquoi pas quand c'est
mon nous le disons par contre moi je
vais vous dire un j'ai assisté à une
visite officielle du président de la
république dans la drôme au tricastin
parlant du nucléaire j'étais là de façon
républicaine pour accueillir le
président de la république
j'ai assisté à un meeting du candidat
ump c'est très clair donc ce que disent
nos porte parole sur ce sujet c'est
qu'il faut vraiment qu aujourd'hui nous
nous posions la question sur tous ses
déplacements accélérer un jour ici un
autre jour là ce sont des de la pré
campagne c'est de la précampagne
présidentielle
alertés les gens c'est aussi parce que
il ya cette campagne encore une fois
présidentielles qui arrivent c'est les
deux choses c'est sur le fond je pense
que nous avons besoin de mettre des
règles plus strictes et plus clair dans
la démocratie est ensuite aussi parce
que de qui se moque t-on quoi le
président de la république va annoncer
sa candidature dans un mois dans deux
mois pourquoi pas d'ailleurs la veille
du premier tour alors tout le monde sait
très bien aujourd'hui qu'il est en
campagne et qu'il fait tous les jours un
discours de campagne lorsqu'il caunes
sur françois hollande sur le quotient
familial en début de semaine sur le
quotient familial début de semaine vient
c'est un discours de campagne électorale
sachant que ces dispositions fort peu de
chances d'être adoptée en retour à
l'assemblée
on va peut-être parler du futur immédiat
vont arriver certainement dans
l'hémicycle à l'assemblée et au sénat
notamment le projet de loi sur la tva
sociale qui sera inclus dans le
collectif budgétaire sur mon début mars
inutile de demander si vous allez voter
contre et là encore détricoter à votre à
votre niveau de sénateur non mais ne
l'ont pas détricoter nous allons faire
de la politique cohérente
la tva sociale qui nous tva anti sociale
il ya tromperie sur la marchandise
tous les français payeront plus de tva
et même lorsqu'on regarde les
déclarations de certains ministres de
jean françois copé qui n'est pas
ministre en 2010 oui c'est une erreur de
françois baroin clinique pour qu'elle
soit efficace frêle augmenté de 5% de
françois fillon qui dit que si on
augmente en 2011 dit si on l'augmenté
aura trop de différence avec
manuel valls qui s'était prononcé bien
sûr est manuel valls mais je rappelle
quand même que aujourd'hui ce n'est pas
ma nouvelle vie mais la tva sociale
c'est une très mauvaise idée
je pense que manuel valls s'est trompé
une très mauvaise idée pour les
entreprises et pour les citoyens
français dire aux français aujourd'hui
que l'on va augmenter les prélèvements
qui toucheront là encore ceux qui ont
les gens qui ont le moins
c'est une très mauvaise idée il savait
la mauvaise réputation selon là bien sûr
mais c'est une fois de plus un argument
électoral pour dire je vais faire
quelque chose je bouge tous les jours
j'ai fait une proposition pour montrer
que je ne suis pas immobile ils ne
veulent pas de cible immobile une bonne
une cible qui bouge
alors pour bouger le bouchon n'arrive
d'ailleurs pas à la rattraper et même
d'ailleurs les amis de monsieur sarkozy
et ses propres les plus proches et amis
n'arrive pas favori le vent puisque là
pour l'incohérence il y en a beaucoup
alors pour finir des guillemins nous
allons parler un petit peu de la une de
libération de vendredi nicolas sarkozy
qui en vivre envisagerait d'inscrire le
mariage gay dans son programme de
candidat pour humaniser son image
analyse le quotidien
là il va clairement chasser sur les
terres du ps si c'est une position de
fond et objective il a raison j'y suis
favorable et nous y sommes favorables
si c'est un nouveau coup je pense que
les problèmes de société valent beaucoup
mieux qu'un coup électoral
en tout cas on peut dire que ça va faire
parler et que le débat va être ouvert
j'ai entendu madame boutin qui disait ce
matin c'est un casus belli pour elle
qu'il ya beaucoup de gens dans l'ump qui
ne sont pas favorables
nous avons d'ailleurs démenti que
nicolas sarkozy ait dit ça mais on s'est
quand même beaucoup de députés qui ont
appuyé cette on sait que c'est un
discussion
en tout cas nous ce que nous disons très
clairement c'est que la famille
aujourd'hui elle a changé elle a changé
il faut tenir compte de ces changements
de la famille ce n'est plus la famille
c'est aussi une famille d'un seul sexe
soient des femmes ou des hommes dans une
zone aussi va l'inscrire françois
hollande va l'inscrire le mariage
homosexuel
il faudra avancer vers l'adoption pour
les couples homosexuels c'est tellement
évident aujourd'hui il y a plusieurs
dizaines de milliers de couples
homosexuels qui ont des enfants
enfin faut regarder la réalité en face
je pense que ce débat c'est un débat de
société moderne et je vous disais au
début de notre entretien que cette
prochaine campagne présidentielle qui
approche à 100 jours
doit partir sur des bases totalement
différente de celle que l'on a connue il
faut renverser la table il faut
décoiffer il faut présenter des choses
tellement nouvelle remettre en cause des
dogmes qui nous ont mis dans le mur de
faire ce que fait le président de la
république avec cette proposition et si
cette proposition venait au parlement
avant la fin de la session devrait
simplement nous la voterons bien sûr en
tout cas on a bien retenu que vous
n'alliez au cours de cette émission que
françois hollande allaient nous
surprendre donc on attend
il va vous surprendre et vous verrez
dans ses propositions dans sa façon
d'aborder les choses et dans son
caractère tranchant
je pense qu'il faut de la
différenciation mais il va vous
surprendre aussi par la modernité et les
nouveautés dans son programme dit
vigneault merci beaucoup d'être venu sur
notre plateau mais pour finir cette
émission nous voulions quand même rendre
un hommage à notre confrère de france
télévisions gilles jacquier tués ce
mercredi à homs en syrie alors qu'ils
étaient en reportage les autorités
syriennes ont annoncé jeudi la création
d'une commission d' enquête sur les
circonstances de la mort de ce
journaliste français merci à tous de
nous avoir suivis merci aude et nous
nous retrouvons la semaine prochaine
pour un nouveau parlement hebdo mujica
matin